oh elden ring now has a gameplay trailer
and release date
january 2022.
people are excited to say the least but
that means we have a half a year until
the game actually arrives
so what better to do than analyze every
content-filled millisecond of this
beautiful equestrian-themed trailer
but before i get into the trailer proper
i'm going to read a short prologue which
has been released on bandai namco's
website it gives a lot of context and
names to the game world and many of its
inhabitants
it reads quote the golden order has been
broken
rise tarnished and be guided by grace to
brandish the power of the elden ring
and become an elden lord in the lands
between
in the lands between ruled by queen
merica the eternal
the elden ring the source of the erd
tree has been shattered
america's offspring demigods all claimed
the shards of the elden ring
known as the great runes and the mad
taint of their newfound strength
triggered a war
the shattering a war that meant
abandonment by the greater will
and now the guidance of grace will be
brought to the tarnished
who were spurned by the grace of gold
and exiled from the lands between
ye dead who yet live your grace long
lost follow the path to the lands
between
beyond the foggy sea to stand before the
elden ring
and become the elden lord now there's a
lot there to unpack
but we can get into most of it during
the actual trailer analysis
just a few other notes from the page
before we get going
quote eldon ring features vast
fantastical landscapes and shadowy
complex dungeons that are connected
seamlessly
traverse the breathtaking world on foot
or on horseback
alone or online with other players and
fully immerse yourself in the grassy
plains
suffocating swamps yes the swamp levels
return naturally
spiraling mountains foreboding castles
and other sites of grandeur on a scale
never seen before in a from software
title charge into battle
pick off enemies one by one using
stealth or even call
upon allies for aid many options are at
your disposal as you decide how to
approach
exploration and combat now that we have
set the stage a little bit
onto the trailer itself we open with our
horse reima
nudging the player character character's
seemingly lifeless body while our likely
new fire keeper type robed woman
dismounts
the robed woman bearing some ring on her
hand addresses us
as the tarnished this game's title for
the player character
like ashen one bearer of the curse and
chosen undead from previous games
one note from the background of the
scene is that water can be heard
dripping and it appears that we are in
some cave or dungeon which is
illuminated by candlelight
considering the tarnished is dead or
asleep or somehow injured on the floor
it seems that the rogue woman came to
this place on vemma
to awaken or save the tarnish to call
them into action
to return as she puts it she reiterates
what the prologue says
ye dead who yet live your grace long
lost follow the path to the lands
between
beyond the foggy sea to stand before the
elden ring
so we once had some grace or affection
that we now lack and we currently reside
somewhere away from the lands between
the game world separated by a foggy sea
now i need to note that the horse name
reima is actually just romanization of
two kanji characters
which mean spirit and horse yeah i will
pronounce
leima lima later in the trailer we see
the horse apparate into existence when
called
so this name scheme of spirit horse
makes sense it also makes more plausible
the idea that to cross the foggy scene
return to the lands between
i.e begin the game's plot we need
something like a spear horse
the foggy sea might be some sort of
spirit realm or barrier keeping the now
graceless tarnished exiled
the rogue woman may be allowing us to
return to the lands between
by way of bringing us the horse and also
the ring on our hand might be
significant
because later on we see the player
character with something like a ring in
their gauntlet
being used to activate an ability the
ring could be some access to grace or
some other power that
allows us to return to the lands between
so there's a lot here about the player
character the tarnished and how they
have lost someone or something's grace
and been exiled
again there are some parallels to the
intro of dark souls 1 being locked in a
jail exiled from the rest of the world
likely the grace lost is the grace of
the greater will which has abandoned
something
likely the lands between as a whole and
maybe whoever the tarnish used to be in
particular
though now we are guided by grace once
lost
which seems to say that we have regained
said grace or we will be in the process
perhaps the ring is important for that a
social media post i described later on
makes it seem like grace will be in some
way a collectible in the game
maybe the greater will has abandoned the
main world and sent the rogue woman to
us
to have us set the lands between back on
the right path
by mending the elden ring okay lots of
little things
then we get our first overworld shot
prominently featuring the slanting
bird tree which bears uncanny
resemblance to the world tree
from the late kintaro mura's berserk
manga series
from software has been open about the
influence berserk has had on their games
so this connection is very reasonable
the erd tree stands grandly but shows
signs of cracking
which is to be expected if its source
the elden ring has now been shattered
the foreground is filled with cracked
lands and stone ruins to some degree
mirroring the mish-mashness found in
parts of dark souls 3
like the drag heap these are the lands
between
and are over world where we should
expect some level of open worldness to
ride around
on raima further concept art and
description on one of from software's
pages talks about how rema is mobile
runs on cliffs and lets us explore
freely and comfortably
this is a quote vast world that connects
seamlessly
end quote which will consist in this
overworld and a
quote huge dungeon created in a
complicated and three-dimensional manner
end quote
i'm assuming a lot of the darker
possibly underground areas we see later
on will be part of this dungeon
and there's going to be lots of
verticality considering that brema can
jump like we see later
and the dungeon is explicitly described
as three-dimensional
so vertical integration in the overworld
and the underworld
that plus descriptions of a vast
connecting world immediately trigger
thoughts of dark souls 1 for me
obviously known for its
interconnectedness and significant
variations in verticality
another shot of the golden erd tree
showering light on the partially
destroyed world
it does look a bit like a pilgrim
butterfly from dark souls 3.
we also see a hunched bean with a
crescent staff and a hood
or helmet the crescent is shallow but it
could be the moon maybe
the earth tree is framed essentially as
the sun in this shot so it would be a
bit of a dichotomy
encampments flying a banner bearing a
sigil of the earth tree
set up in defense around a large
scraggly mountain crater
if the earth tree has broken from the
ground which might be the case given its
previously noted cracking
and pilgrim butterfly look then this
could have been its original trunk
i'm not sure what to make of the army
bearing the sigil they are almost
certainly enemies at least
us but i have a hard time believing the
urge tree to be a force of evil
with some evidence found later on it
could be that the urgery sigil
represents one of the factions that took
part in the shattering war
the others being wolf and lion factions
the tree faction could be that of the
queen
herself and maybe other parts of the
royal family and it finds some
motivation in the tree
if the tree did break from the earth it
could need to die for a new one to take
its place
for a natural process to occur maybe the
tree faction blinded by faith
doesn't want to put up for any harm to
the tree even if it's necessary
and this would lead to them being our
enemy there also seems to be some sort
of tall spectral banner off to the right
this could be connected to the player's
specter summoning cube
or the horse's spectral double jump both
of which we will see
later or it could be something just
completely different but within the
world of spectral
spirit kind of stuff like the foggy sea
or a castle that we see
later on with a similar blue glow up
next is a destroyed but in some kind of
stasis cathedral of either the golden
order which the rogue woman narrator
says has broken to its core
or a wolf action which may have once
been a part of the order
considering the state of this chapel i'd
say she's right but even if it was in
mint condition
the pillars are still filled with what
looks to be dog or wolf skeletons
in their construction and directly below
the order's sigil
is a person maybe a maiden surrounded by
wolves
probably a higher chance of protection
being implied here than danger
so this is quite the ominous
congregation even when things are going
good
and there are some strong lupine themes
as well a connection to the later shown
wolfman is very apparent
as i mentioned this wolf order could be
one of the three or more
warring factions standing at odds with
those in the tree faction and the lion
themed order we find later at a possible
royal castle
the golden order seems to be a religious
system which was pretty all-encompassing
in the lands between its destruction is
in the first
line of the prologue and the possible
sigil comes up a lot
like the outro image of the trailer for
example four semi-concentric rings
and three upwards-facing arcs one
seemingly emanating energy down to all
the others
the four rings could be the shards of
the elden ring and the arks i'm not so
sure on
this sigil is found in the wolf chapel
and if it does represent the order
it could be that the wolf faction maybe
along with all the others
were part of the golden order before it
broke down due to the faction warring
so the golden order would be the
all-encompassing order of all the
factions before they split apart
moving on we see a forest and bonfire
surrounded by unmoving figures who
appear to be in a position of wailing
all having their arms bent back to push
their hands against their heads
again not a very happy group of people
but these ones might also just be dead
or statuefied considering their lack of
movement
then the tarnished featuring a luscious
set of white locks
moves towards the setting sun so there
is a sun in this game
it's not just the earth tree then
appears rema out of thin air and we get
a riding montage
nothing too noteworthy other than
looking cool and the fact that we're
riding away from the earth tree so maybe
a section of the world
more removed from the center area and
then this shot
a castle in the distance which looks at
least a bit off axis
and on the left may be a church that has
had its lower level
gutted plus a big tree but not quite
urgery massive
and not glowy the fog covered middle
could be the foggy sea
or it could just be from soft making an
ominous foggy area
i would lean somewhat to the latter
maybe it entails a giant boss fight all
throughout the forest that you have to
fight while on horseback
not too out of the question given the
horseback boss fight we see later on
the next shot gives us a better view of
the crooked castle
plus a few shining items below the
bridge this would mean that we can to
some degree go down to the foggy forest
area
or at least the edge of it the er tree
light is more prominent in the scene and
makes me think it'll have some kind of
relevance to the game's narrative
maybe as a new tree to replace the old
one the archery has lost its source so
when the elden ring is mended or made
new
perhaps it needs or necessitates the
growth of a new erd tree
big bell boy i don't have much comment
on other than it's very imposing
and a demarcated force
the giant bell also has relevance in
dark souls 1 with all the bell ringing
that was central to progression in that
game
it is bound to have some sort of similar
potency in this game though of what
nature is uncertain
it could be needed to ring to progress
the game make it harder like insecure
or something new next is some cargo or a
vip surrounded by some zombie soldiers
and maybe more cognizant knights
being pulled in the luxury cart by some
gutterly yoked spike-faced giants
who judging from a fight later on may
not stay permanently chained down
nonetheless quite grotesque in the first
shot we see one of the zombie soldiers
carrying a banner but we cannot see the
sigil as it is facing the wrong way
perhaps these are more of the er tree
banner zombies it does look like they're
moving toward the archery but the
tarnish gets in their way highlighting
some of the horseback sword fighting
mechanics
we also get to see the young big tree
again whose color scheme make me not
want to take note of it
but continued presence and dominating
size demand i
at least make mention we then see a room
of arms foreshadowing another boss
likely the same character as is depicted
grandly in the painting
say for one caveat the painting looks
like it has a giant lion head behind or
next to the human one
this is an obvious connection to the
lion faction
when we see the likely subject later on
he has become a deformed
multi-armed mess as we walk a male voice
begins to speak
in full it says quote foul tarnished in
search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish thy flame so
not someone too happy with our stated
goals i'm not sure if flame of ambition
has any deeper meaning
than literal ambition but it's not
surprising to find npcs or enemies and
souls games that would prefer you dead
to completing your objective
a short look at a massive face flattened
and conjoined with the rock and ground
this could be a slain boss but the blend
into the background makes me question
that possibility
if not a boss it could be a static nbc
that has become part of the world
maybe a demigod that didn't fight over
the ring shards
or perhaps another older force that has
suffered like the erd tree
due to the rings breaking we see some
continuation of the underground area
with the player overlooking a tomb
with one standing statue the beard looks
almost tentacley
and the arms are frail a screenshot from
the website shows us
on horseback fighting something that i
would say looks like the statue
in a forest so this one could possibly
pop out and attack us maybe in defense
of whatever lies beyond the lower door
or maybe the tiny plane looking
creatures are the only line of defense
the foreground architecture reminds me
just a bit of the tomb of giants
or other underworld sections of dark
souls 1.
then we get our cute little
semi-anthropomorphic vases
likely seeking revenge for all their
brethren that have been passively slain
and passed from soft games perhaps there
will be some natural pots and some
mimic-esque enemy pots
just swinging at all the pots would
solve this issue but it's not really as
much fun as rolling through them though
also in a gameplay picture from the
website there is a yellow white glowing
item
to pick up near the pot on an instagram
post from the elden ring account
they say quote the lands between basked
in the pure light of the greater will
before the shattering
slivers of its blessing yet remain in
hidden pockets where lost graces
wait to be found so this item could be a
lost grace that we use to gain power
like the rogue woman mentioned as these
are pickups they probably won't function
like souls from previous games
but maybe they could be skill points for
skill trees somewhat ala sakura
a quick shot of more underground dungeon
some bones on the ground indicate a
return of skeleton enemies
and the next shot shows them in new form
swagged out with a crown and gaping
dragon type body
during the fight we can see some yellow
green smoke or vapor rise from the back
of the skeleton beast
i would assume this indicates a status
effect it can inflict like poison toxin
or something of the sort
it also features a kind of white mask or
face instead of a traditional skull
which is a theme we'll see more of later
on
with the crown it draws similarities to
the queen which is another person who
sports a
face replace full mask we also get to
see a visceral attack which is
unsurprising but welcome to have back
on to a grand castle partially destroyed
war
torn possibly the castle of the royal
family
this is almost certainly not the castle
we saw in the background crossing the
bridge
but it could be the castle or stronghold
off to the left of our first shot of the
lands between
and soon we are greeted by who i presume
owns the voice we have just been hearing
the timing of the words someone really
sets it in
fitting thematically a monkey being all
chimered up with scragglehorns
protruding from his head
horns not to unlike those on our lama
along with a scorpion tail
he sports a simple staff but that gives
way to a gold white
thrown curved blade it looks like he
summoned it out of thin
air which may mean it's something like a
miracle given its visual flair
it is an ability of a kind of magic or
power of some other kind maybe having to
do with the ring or greater will
because immediately follows another gold
white apparition weapon
this time a hammer as the tarnish
summons their own magic sword
enhancement
we see lion banners on the ramparts
possibly the sigil of the royal family
or some part of the family
as we see another king-like boss wrap
the same sigil later on
that makes me think this fighter could
be a lower demigod or some servant or
lieutenant of the royal family
or of a specific royal some connection
obviously exists if he is guarding the
path to a royal stronghold
lastly the urge replacement in this shot
would support the idea that this castle
structure is what we see in the
beginning overworld shot on the far
left once we cut scene defeat
scragglehorn face the rogue woman takes
over narration
reminding us that we will fight and die
in an unending curse
which probably did not need to be said
considering this is a fromsoft game
but maybe it's just driving home the
point that because we are tarnished
we have been cursed with continuing life
riding out we see a white item to pick
up
and an orange glow that could be some
other form of consumable or pickup
we see two more off to the left and one
looks like it could be
a body maybe i'm not really sure in
another game i'd say they could be
explosives but they seem somewhat oddly
placed for that here
also note that the hanging skeletons are
still somehow holding on to their
weapons
dedicated fighters that or they're still
alive as zombies or something of the
like
just hanging there angry we then get a
look at some grandfathered in skyrim
horse movement
it seems that the blue spots in the map
will let our horse super jump or maybe
the player character
can project them i kind of doubt this
one we again see the stripped-out church
building that i don't recognize from
anywhere else in the trailer
unless it's maybe the stasis
wolf chapel but that one seemed to have
more of a lower body
and a broken up top as opposed to this
one followed by some showcasing of the
improvements made to the skyrim horse
combat
improvements like having horse-specific
combat
in the next scene it looks like the
tarnish is sporting some new drip along
with a new haircut unless for some
reason this isn't the player character
which i think we can safely infer it is
considering they were riding rhema
we see some spins and jumps in sword
swinging somewhat allah fair and
greatsword or old wolf curved sword
from dark souls 3 along with what looks
like a ring on the back of our left hand
which begins to charge up gold emitting
similar effects
as scragglehorn when he used his miracle
type weapons
so this could be for a miracle type
attack or something like a sakura weapon
art
either way definitely some form of a
charge up into an in all likelihood
flourishing attack
perhaps the grace we find around the
world acts as skill points to unlock and
upgrade attacks from this gauntlet
and this gauntlet having the ring on it
could be the ring from the robed woman
in the very start of the trailer and we
use it throughout our journey in the
lands between
ah a good rest by the bonfire there are
some slight effects around the player
here may be indicating healing or some
status buff
if the latter this could be a change to
how bonfires work
there are gold pedals or leaves in the
air likely falling from the er tree
which i must say is really looking like
it could be detached from the ground
right here
like maybe it's just getting covered up
by the tower but if we engage csi
zoom enhanced technology toward the
lower left under the open arch
which seems pretty clear blue like
there's nothing extra behind it blocking
our line of sight there is not one
ounce of gold light from the earth tree
which we would expect if it went
straight down
i would assume if the tree just be out
here soaring more than the kids from
high school musical
then it's either going to die or
transform pretty soon
which is where our hot boy young tree
could step up and shine
turning into urge tree part 2 for elden
ring 2
though elden ring 2 would be in this
game because maybe we
make the new elden ring so eldon ring 2
is the end of elder ring
1. and for further support of this
theory we can go back to the elden ring
teaser trailer
and see where the blacksmith is
hammering that's right
it's a giant tree trunk so big that i'm
pretty sure there's just one tree it
could have come from
speaking of mordecai over at eldon ring
news has a video talking about some
unused concept art which shows an
even more explicit tree theme for that
shot of the blacksmith
so pack it up boys and girls urgery
floating theory
is confirmed also there's a really big
moon or other planet out by the right
not sure what's up with that now it
would be wild if that's where our exile
was and the fog you see was legit space
or some spirit world separating the two
planets
but if you did have a moon that close
your tidal forces would be
insane and most life probably wouldn't
be able to happen as we see it
next we get a wolfman howl which seems
like another clear homage to berserk
specifically the main character guts
especially when he wears the berserker
armor and turns into basically a wolf
man
the dark fantasy influence of berserk
especially on fromsoft games
is immense and with murasan's recent
passing this is a touching gesture to
his decades-long work
and its impact this character is in all
likelihood part of the wolf faction
and i think is the only one we see
representing the faction in this trailer
following is the cube which seems quite
important in some form of spell casting
it appears to have lines of words
written all around it
not that that will really come into play
gameplay wise but lore wise the
inscribed words could be a source of
power
or dictate what kind of spell it is the
cube dissolves and rings glow in the
character's left hand
indicating a spell about to be cast the
two blue phantoms seem to correlate with
the cube as opposed to mean co-op
summons
but maybe the cube is used for co-op
summons who knows phantom whip and
firebow rollshot means
sunlock's galore if this is a spell it
is going to be
chaos in pvp so can't wait to see how
meme youtubers
abuse it to the absolute fullest this
gameplay image shows the cube being
utilized to summon a bird person
familiar as well
though with more of a purple tinge than
blue though that could just be different
color grading for the image
this could mean that we get a range of
animals as summons to fight in battle
with
again some fun pvp implications also of
note here is the spike headed giant is
now wielding the stake which was being
used to enslave the others of its kind
so maybe the other ones we see pulling
the carriage can bust out their stakes
and attack us with them
a white four-winged butterfly dragon
spewing fire lava in what looks like the
previous super mountain crater
the dragon which we later get to fight
on horseback
evolution of dark souls this is the
dragon heaves flames as the tarnished
rides by with a short staff looking kind
of like a flipped sword
maybe even a coiled sword likely to be
used for magic
it summons red lightning from the sky
finally getting its turn to play with
the element after gwen hogged it for the
entire last trilogy
and what's in the background you know
it's hot boy young tree
looking all black and about to straight
die as the sky turns blood red
but what kind of from soft game would
this be if the sky didn't turn
into a death eclipse also the sky
turning different color
could have some relevance to the redness
of the lightning for the dragon
and the other red magic we see later on
in the trailer
plus if you look closely in this
transition you can see our horse
execute a double jump which could either
be a default or unlocked ability
again showing the blue apparative light
then arrives an acrobatic lion boss
fight
filled with red magic we briefly see a
feline head and hear a distinctive roar
but important to note is that this fight
with someone from the lion faction
is happening in the wolf faction stasis
chapel
this boss does invoke the lionhead
painting we saw before
but i think it's more that he's part of
the faction as opposed to being the
painting subject
evidence still seems to point to the
many armed boss we see later on
being the subject of that painting also
the rogue woman continues her previous
comments about our continued deaths
saying of them quote for how else is a
champion
or lord to be born the word champion
sounds when there's a slow-mo on
lionhead here so we can infer
through rigorous deduction that he or it
is a champion of some kind
likely of the lion faction though i'm
not sure what else we can infer from the
fact that they are a champion
other than just a prominent fighter or
strong boss
lastly in the sequence the tarnished
bears a cloak that has some previously
unseen
sigil on its back possibly a downward
thrusting sword
there also could be a fleur-de-lis up at
its top too
i don't believe this sigil shows up
anywhere else in the trailer but chances
are
it has some significance in the game
world we just don't know what yet
or it could just be fashion souls which
would be totally okay
when the rogue woman says lord the shot
changes to the red-haired valkyrie
featured prominently in the teaser as
she attaches her prosthetic right arm
we can see her face has some form of rot
or disease or burn on its right side
much like what we saw on her left arm in
the teaser
the word lord is emphasized on her so it
follows she is a lord
at the very least one of the demigods
likely bearer of one of the great runes
she is then seen reverse stepping on the
tarnished via impalement
with the world's longest sword in a very
arbor themed
den surrounded by white flowers the tree
theme could be that we're at the old
base of the earth tree
or that we're at the trunk of the
potential new herb tree
we've seen throughout the trailer white
flowers can represent purity
reverence or death rebirth and new life
the final possibility would be fitting
due to our shown death coinciding
with the rogue woman speaking of the
word born
this kind of thematic touch would also
give credence to the location being at
one of the two trees
one dying and one beginning life she
also bears a cape with a hard to see
but definitely there he looked close
enough tree sigil of gold
indicating that she is aligned with the
tree faction
maybe it's de facto leader considering
the queen we see later on
looks pretty holed up so she could be a
daughter of the queen
which would fit with her being a high
demigod and lord
next we finally find our foreshadowed
many armboy
who says well a lowly tarnished
plain as a lord
we first see him touching a dragon head
which could be before the fight
or for phase two considering we do later
see him with a dragon head attached to
his arm
his cloak sheds away and we see many
arms attached in a worse than
frankenstein manner
the axe bears a lion sigil and the tone
is very royal
he wears a crown is mad at our pretense
of lordlyhood
and commands we kneel this could be the
king
now fallen corrupted and deformed or it
could be some other demigod
like a firstborn prince who has broken
from his family and their tree faction
to form his own lion faction the
painting in the arm room and the
painting we later see of the king are
not horribly similar
so i'm inclined to think of this as a
prince or someone of that sort
if a prince he could be brother to the
valkyrie
then comes a steroided up kirk of thorns
with glowing red tendrils wrapped around
his body and some red magic somewhat
like that of the lion champion
maybe again this is in relation to the
sky turning red
the kind of magic this time is different
though because it pulls you in like the
force as opposed to being just a blast
of energy like
we saw in the lion fight then a dragon
but not the dragon we saw before this
one has no arms only one set of wings
flies over an area similar in biome to
the area which featured the one enemy
with the crescent staff
the river and blue flowers match keeping
the flame fighting going
is a smog looking fellow up with a
hammer which could
kinda look like it has a dragon themed
head
did someone say ornstein also check the
jewels on the tarnished got a bit of ice
to fight fire head over here
and there seems to be a sigil on the
wall behind fatty doesn't quite look
like the tree though
but could be something related though we
can't reliably place big guy here on any
particular faction
unless some of you can see something in
his armor that i can't
next an axe wielding wood giant is
framed between us
and the erd tree possibly protecting it
or otherwise keeping us from getting to
it
the giant is powered by some light
coming from its inside maybe a portion
of power from the earth tree
or one of those gold white miracle
powers we saw before which could be a
power from the greater will
it also looks like our sword is broken
which would either mean
our weapons can physically break now an
evolution of durability
or that broken sword is a normal weapon
that is viable for fighting actual
enemies
either way could be a growth from what
we've seen in previous games
the tower in the background would put us
behind the cracked road from the first
overworld shot which fits with the tree
placement
then comes anor londo 3 maybe the castle
we saw from the crack bridge
surrounded by glowing blue magic kind of
like that which is associated with our
horse
may be the spirit world the castle is
also in good shape relative to
everything else in the world so some
level of separation is apparent
we see that sneaking makes its return
from securo which we employ to ambush a
group of sorcerers that don't seem to
like showing their faces
along with the sneaking could be some
skill trees like we saw in securo maybe
weapon arts of that kind return
and that's what we saw earlier with the
flipping attacks here we see a pretty
sick
jumping magic staff attack so either way
we're going to have some pretty tight
move sets
what then follows is a return of magic
laser obliterating another of these
spike faces
then big magic moose elk oh flying
should mean that description too
as santa's reject takes to the sky we
can see that we are surrounded by
shallow water
and a host of servant apparitions we
sport a domi helmet previously seen
and two hand claws and interesting
weapon choice to fight a giant flying
moose that can probably
shoot magic at us we move on by bowing
to this bloody handed masked figure
maybe as part of some sort of covenant
and then we get someone who looks a
little bit similar
the highest of all masked memers the
apparent queen herself
mother of demigods a liner of the tree
faction if you look
really really close at her dress and
squint king baldwin looking leper
america the eternal watched over by a
portrait of the king
and one horn-shielded guard who we'll
see later in grand action
also a visual note is this mirror or
plate
i can't think of any significance such
an object would have
considering if queen is a leper or
otherwise marred by the same rot on the
valkyrie
she probably does not want to look at
herself much but the object really
stands out visually in this scene
maybe enough that it could support the
following idea
so we saw a possible florida lee before
an extremely prevalent french symbol
used in everything from denoting saints
to the boy scout emblem
this object could simply be a french
platter like these ones highlighted in a
wiki article that only exists on french
wikipedia detailing the plate as part of
a roman treasure found in lyon france
even further the appearance of the queen
bears strong resemblance to the
depiction of king baldwin in the famous
movie the kingdom of heaven
who wore a similar mask to cover up his
leprosy
along with total body coverings of claw
while there is no evidence that the
actual king wore such a mask
the actual king was a french lineage so
this visual connection
could be a further french emphasis this
french connection doesn't have to mean
much
especially because i can't think of what
it would mean but it could just be an
inspiration for visuals or aesthetics
so given all that conspiracy level
connection drawing it's nice that
miyazaki was kind enough to give the
next shot of us fans scouring the
trailer for lore and
info that we missed after our 30 second
watch thanks miyazaki you really
captured the feeling of desperately
searching for lore in these games
following is a many fingered hand fitted
with rings rushing us atop a snow peaked
mountain
it looks like the tarnish is the one
spewing these blackish flames
so this could be some form of pyromancy
making its return
it could be tied in with grace upgrades
too
also don't let this foreground deceive
you we can learn just as much from the
background which puts us closer to the
er tree than we've ever been
it makes sense we're up on a mountain
high enough to have snow so we're closer
to the top of the tree
perhaps we climb the mountain to reach
the top of the tree or some other higher
section
for some plot purpose continuing the
flame plus rushing at us motif
is a giant head cart spewing flames in
all directions as we approach it with
spear and shield
as it gets closer the face bears some
resemblance to the large flat
face we saw in the cavern before
especially with the tendrils emitting
from the bottom
then is a fire eye that might be tied to
the sigil behind smog
it houses 8 small circles around one
bigger one
perhaps eight chief bosses otherwise i
don't see any connections or
significance
other than spooky strong enemy
then a giant lacking pupils in cold air
likely at the top of the mountain we saw
before
it could possibly be guarding the
entrance to the top of the tree or
whatever else is important on top of the
mountain
the hair is a bit more orange but very
similar to that of the valkyrie
so there could be some relation between
the two both at least seem to be enemies
of note and strength
then the player is naked and grasped by
a glowing earthy hand
i think the previous wood giant we saw
is too woody for this
it could be something like the giant
rope being from securo
which acts as a form of transport to
different realms
its glow could be some power from the
earth tree or the greater will
next comes the queen's knight in action
flying to the air with golden wings
while its body glows in a kind of red
blue hue
definitely a strong fighter and likely
an engaging boss fight
then we go back to many arms who we
fight in a cemetery maybe we are
fighting him in different areas a
courtyard a graveyard
and then we finish with a cinematic
which seems to show us kind of close to
the middle or top of the
tree but that could also just be
perspective funk
maybe we are here as seen from the
initial shot
we cut to eldon ring just to return to
armboy reppin the dragon arm in front
of the aforementioned citadel notably
burying the tree sigil
this makes me think more that the tree
sigil could be the queen
or royal family and the armboy is a
prince or someone else from the family
who split
into or to create the lion faction
and there we go that's the trailer we
find on the end screen the tarnished
among dead enemies and the grand elden
ring
symbol behind perhaps the sigil of the
broken
golden order clearly colored gold white
like we've seen
many times throughout the trailer the
gold order could have united all of the
factions before it was broken
with eldon rings destruction and the
warring its focus could have been the
greater will
and when the fighting began and the
focus was lost the greater will
abandoned so i think some big takeaways
from this trailer are the differing
factions which will impact the story and
maybe covenants
there's definitely some analogies to
draw between the
fighting houses of say a song of ice and
fire
and these differing factions fighting
for power there's a whole host of dope
looking bosses
significant movement and exploration via
the horse and a pretty
varied world both in design mood and
combat
if fromsoft can pull off strong
interconnection this could be quite a
grand world to play in
which makes sense given george r.r
martin's involvement to beef up the
narrative connection
and interplay well this script is
nearing
six and a half thousand words and this
recording is almost going to be an
hour-long raw
so i need to stop i hope you've enjoyed
and if you have any other theories or
think i missed something or engaged in
unjustified conjecture please let me
know in the comments
i welcome any and all theory crafting
there and i would be happy to see more
discussion
also many if not most of the things that
i've been talking about and ideas i've
presented
are not my own findings or ideas or have
not been found in isolation i've been
spending a good amount of time in the
elder ring subreddit and the discord and
there are a lot of great lore hunters
there diving through the trailer
if you're looking for more of that check
out either of those places linked in the
description
thanks for watching and i'll be sure to
do more elden ring content as we get
more info
and when the game releases